which company should be broken up in
order rank them
and why worst behaved tech companies and
why which one should be broken up first
who's had the most negative impact on
humanity
number one i mean i re i yeah i
it's almost like you're doing my talking
points for facebook here but i'm big on
breaking facebook up i think the
uh two acquisitions they were stupidly
allowed to
to make in instagram and and whatsapp
prevented real competition in
uh in social media and in social
networks and
absolutely they should be broken up and
that that's just one remedy though
i think we should break up facebook i
think we should break up google i think
we should break up amazon
um i think there's probably also a case
for breaking up apple
but i think this this core idea that
we're allowing
tech conglomerates that they can have
one area where they're really dominant
and then they can use that dominance in
that one monopoly area like google is
doing with search engines
to capture monopolies in other areas
either through acquisitions or conquest
it's just bunk like all of antitrust law
and practice was sort of focused around
this right that we didn't want the big
trusts
that just owned everything i've been
reading matt staller's goliath
book that details how the trust busters
in the
in the 20s and 30s uh took on jp morgan
and took on standard oil and
all these other things and you're like
jesus yeah why can't we have some of
that why can't we have a president who's
sort of
just out there decrying the fact of
monopolies
uh monopolist capitalists well yeah the
problem was the economy you the the
it's how you define it is the issue
because they defined it as like are the
users
suffering and the users were suffering
and when you look at android or youtube
or
chrome or gmail and all these free
services tremendous suffering
tremendous suffering exploitation of
privacy
right so targeted advertisement i don't
think anybody wants the worst evils ever
been inflicted on the internet
and it's what's given rise to facebook
and google
so we need to attack targeted
advertisement head on
my preferred solution is simply to ban
it that you cannot show advertisement
based on
uh personal don't you like targeted ads
don't you like seeing an ad that's
better i mean you're probably like no
ads but if you did cnn would you like
one that's better no
this whole idea that relevant ads are a
bonus
to people is is a complete manufactured
talking point by the attack
industry i like i like seeing targeted
ads better but
you know what but then but then you
think through it and you don't like when
when i talk to
um sort of take the example of
someone who just became pregnant this is
a example that's been recounted over and
over again because it happens all the
time
let's say they go down to buy a
pregnancy test at cvs
that sales that gets sold to a data
broker
that data broker sells it on to either
facebook or google or someone else
and all of a sudden before you've even
told maybe your spouse or
oh yeah you know it's happening right in
the house you start getting ads
for essentially like hey here's a baby
stroller here's uh what to do
uh how did it happen here's an adoption
agency
um uh actually you should get an
abortion like
yeah but you know the punchline is it
happens to every computer in the house
because they're using your ip address
for your router right so like
every now and then i'm like why am i
seeing
bikinis and bathing suits and then i
like walk by my wife's computer and
she's buying
you know swimsuits that's your brother
and i'm like this is not my browsing
habits i didn't search for this
but i see the brands i recognize the
brand she buys and then she sees the
brands i buy
which is hilarious yeah it's [ __ ] it's
not good and you know what i think one
of the reasons it's really so not good
is because these companies like facebook
and google they have found that this
is the golden opportunity to turn [ __ ]
content into gold content no longer
matters in sort of
any sense of abstract idea of quality
the only thing that matters is
engagement
so if you can find the most outraging
content that's going to be the most
engaging content
the most diversified content that's the
one that performs best for us because it
just doesn't matter what the content is
it doesn't matter what discussion
eyeball is fixed
then you can show them ads based on the
personal data not on the content
which you were someone who made content
right like web blogs inc and so on
wouldn't you want that like say an
engadget had could command a premium
because they had like tech it was it was
the reason why it's based on that yeah
the reason i'm not in the content
business anymore to be honest is because
it's too hard to do it's too hard to do
because then we had people who are
targeting
engadget and so somebody would run an
add-on and gadget
like a small ad buy they would cookie
everybody then they would sell that
information to somebody else and say
would you like to buy a gadget users yes
and now they've stolen your entire
audience they stole the audience
and so nick denton and i when he was
doing gawker we were like are you
letting this other third party on and
they're like
he's like yeah they're sending us like a
check for 3000 a month i was like i
think they're selling gizmodo and
engadget yes
right on the side to samsung and samsung
was buying direct from us and no longer
buying direct and he was like oh yeah
should we kick them out and we basically
colluded to kick them out we clicked out
all the ad networks because we're like
this is screwing up direct sales so what
if you didn't need a cartel to do
protection what if you had basic
regulations that
simply said you cannot do targeted ads
the
value of say an engadget would go
through the roof
like tech journalism is one of the most
profitable ones because like people
[ __ ] buy phones all the time and they
want to read reviews
so this is the natural place to place
these kinds of advertisements
this used to happen targeted
advertisement is a new phenomenon
like we literally it's really the birth
of it right
yeah it's super effective it's too
effective now
everybody in the content business is
just going to subscription i'm going to
subscription with inside.com we have
advertising we did over a million
dollars last year i'm like you know what
the advertising we have to concede at
some point that we're not going to be
able to build an at-scale advertising
company
and just start charging people 10 bucks
a month for the content
and and no one is and it is because
google and facebook
literally took i just did a
congressional testimony on this topic in
front of the house antitrust
subcommittee
and one of the data points i pulled out
as part of that research was i think it
was 2016 and 2017.
99 of all the growth in internet
advertising
captured by two companies 99 like it
sounds like it's not even real
but 99 was captured by facebook of the
game year over year went to them right
and it makes sense because if you've
ever placed ads you're like oh my god
i can target and retarget and find
exactly my audience and do these
lookalike audiences through ai
and it's just so effective and then if
you don't do it
now your competitors are doing it so
you're in an arms race i know you took
that was exactly my argument my argument
in front of contrast was
that you're at a grave competitive
disadvantage if you do not take a
uh sort of avalanche of the surveillance
capitalist
system that is powering this ad engine
and that's terrible
that we're handing over an entire
industry internet advertisement to
essentially two companies and a little
extra
is not good and the consequences of that
are starkly clear there was just another
newspaper i don't know conglomerate or
whatever that went out of business
um or went into bankruptcy that that
runs the miami herald and
30 other local newspapers do you want to
trade
all the local newspapers in all of
america and you know what you get back
you get facebook
you're like holy [ __ ] what a bad trade
what a bad deal as the president would
say right
it's a terrible [ __ ] deal for the
country it's terrible yeah i mean i
think
if you and if you look at it it's such
an easy solution
we have to just redefine what antitrust
is and how it works
and then just look at the behavior of
the companies the if the behavior is
really bad it makes it
really easy to say you know what and the
incentives the incentives
yeah why are facebook and google
collecting all this personal data
because it's so valuable because they
can sell they should have
the liabilities involved with collecting
and storing personal data would not be
worth it at all if they could not
monetize it in the way that they did so
all these privacy scandals would keep
having over and over and over again
would i mean if not entirely largely
disappear because it would simply be
hugely unprofitable to run the risk of
collecting personal data you do not have
a legitimate express
specified consent for um just to what
store it and the thing that really gets
me is that
um i think this is gonna would hurt
facebook more than anyone who was
really the ones who need to hurt the
most like if you take google for example
google has
um as intent when you show up on their
website and you search for
used cars los angeles that's all the
intent you need you don't need any
personal data
you don't need to be you said what you
want like who's pregnant and who's not
there's enough intent in that search